finally we have got to the point where i
can actually say i have played halo
infinite
and we're going to talk about that today
we're going to be reviewing halo
infinite for the xbox series x i have a
lot to say about this game i have a lot
some positive some negatives but let's
break that down let's get into it but
before we get on with the video
definitely hit that like button if you
guys enjoyed the video you can always
subscribe to the channel for weekly
content and don't forget to go there and
follow me at twitter lord addict iop and
don't forget every sunday at 1 pm
eastern 11 a.m 11 a.m
eastern when we're doing the football
stuff you can always catch the iron
lords podcast on the youtube channel
you're seeing this review on and that
will any further ado let's talk about
halo infinite i would show a boxer
something i don't got a box for halo
infinite got the thing digitally but
let's let's roll it
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord addicts
here coming at you with from iop you
guys know how it is we're gonna be
reviewing halo infinite for the xbox
series x now for those of you that's
been following the podcast for a long
time you know
that in terms of halo i've always been
very very open on my distrust on certain
things that 343 has done in the past and
whether or not i feel like they would be
able to hold that lamp up and really
shine bright when it comes to the future
of halo infinite and the future of halo
in general and i've always said that
halo infinite is that breaking point for
343 and they need to make sure that this
game goes out without a hitch and it's
as best as it possibly can be so like i
said thank you for microsoft and xbox
for providing the iron lords podcast
with the review code that we did really
break down this game we wouldn't played
it i myself played
about 15 to 20 hours i did a lot of the
stuff you can do now i can't say i did
everything in halo infinite but i did
play a good sizable amount of halo
infinite now clearly we're not going to
be really going too much into detail
about the story of halo infinite because
i'm not trying to ruin the experience
for the viewers i want you guys to
experience a lot of this for yourself
but we will talk about whether or not i
feel like the story and the narrative
that was in the story lived up to my
expectations when it came to halo
infinite now let's talk about halo
infinite story now i played a good
amount i played the entire story i went
through a lot of the the audio vlogs
that was in this game for those of you
that don't know when you're going
through the game you'll be picking up
these audio vlogs kind of like stuff
that's in dead space where it gives you
a little bit more of a back history and
some information that happened during
what happened between five and infinite
so i really enjoyed that i did a lot of
that i did the entire story i did a lot
of the you know the far cry formula
people like saying where you go through
you capture maps and
what i can actually say is i'm actually
about in the middle when it comes to the
story i love what they did i think it's
a fantastic story and it's told well
but i do think because i am such a huge
fan of the halo franchise and i've
played halo 5. i've played halo 4. i
played halo wars 2. i have a little bit
more knowledge in terms of what's going
on in the background with the lore than
the average gamer would coming into halo
infinite keep in mind halo infinite is
going to be on game pass so a lot of
people are going to go into this with
brand new eyes that might not
necessarily have played a halo game in
the past and i think that's the thing
that
343 did very well in this game sure is
it better for you to have played these
older games and you don't know what's
going on yes i recommend go everyone
going everyone at least watch the
cutscenes for halo wars 2 because i know
that's not a first person shooter and
some people aren't necessarily going to
like the way that that gameplay is given
because some people want what we're
experiencing in halo infinite and at
least go back and play halo 5 because
you're going to understand a little bit
more that's going into halo infinite but
do you need to play these games i would
say not i feel like 343 probably went
back and they said look
clearly there wasn't a lot of people
that was very impressed with the story
of halo 5. i for myself
thought that it was very underwhelming
and i felt like there was a lot of
little things they could have did to
make that story a lot better clearly we
saw reused bosses there was
there was chapters with just talking to
a couple people so i think that 343 took
it back and they're like look we really
enjoy what's going on here let's make
sure that whatever is in halo infinite
is able to stand in its own merits what
i mean by that is when you play halo
infinite they give you enough background
story to find out what happened in halo
5 to find out what happened in halo wars
2. sure you might not know everything
that goes on in this game when they talk
about certain backstories and you would
have to play those games if you wanted
to really know what they're talking
about but i don't think it's necessary
for you to play these games to know 100
of what's going on all you have to do is
play halo infinite and you would be
understanding on everything that's going
on clearly if you didn't play the bungee
ones and you didn't play reach you might
be a little bit more
confused than some other people but i
don't think you need to play those games
to know what's going on i think they did
a really good job on telling halo
infinite story without knowing a whole
lot of knowledge on what happened to
halo 5 and halo wars 2 and i think
that's a really good thing because like
i said this is coming into game pass so
i do think that they needed to have a
good middle grind i would have expected
a little bit more
of you know answers that was
i felt like should have been answered
that wasn't but keep in mind this is
more like a like
most halo games most games in general
was like an iron man one through three
references where you know you're getting
that story with those three movies to
hear it looks like this is gonna be more
of a you know
working your way up to the avengers
thing where you know they're gonna tell
the banished storyline then you know
maybe they'll tell another storyline in
the future and etc etc i think that's
probably how they're going to work this
i don't know i'm just saying how i feel
like the story looks like it's going to
be gone but i will say that a lot of
people were very fearful when it come to
halo wars and not halo wars halo
infinite my bad is is this game gonna
have a beginning middle and end we saw a
lot of references to destiny and destiny
is kind of a games of service tell the
story throughout the years through
expansions and through seasons and then
have that big moment at the end of that
whole 10-year cycle and to my opinion it
is going to be kind of like this in halo
and halo infinite but i don't think it's
going to be as bad as destiny did it
when i played halo infinite i did feel
like they answered all the questions
that i had for that particular game sure
i personally felt like they could have
answered some more questions
you know particularly during halo 5 and
how certain things happened in halo
infinite but i understand why they
didn't do it because they wanted to make
sure that everybody knew what was going
on i just personally felt like they
could have did a little bit better on
that kind of scenario but at the end of
the day
i do feel like they went out there and
they achieved a very solid experience
and a good narrative focused story that
everyone's going to enjoy i don't think
no one's really going to
play this game they might nitpick it a
little bit because i did i did nitpick
it a little bit and i can't really go
too much into that without spoiling it
but regardless of those nitpicks
i cannot tell you guys i didn't put this
down like
i played this from beginning to end
after i really got into it
almost the entire time i i would go to
sleep for like six seven hours come
right back get right back on halo
infinite and usually when i do that i'm
hooked and i really enjoyed this i think
you guys are in for a treat in terms of
narrative and in halo infinite i think
they did a good job in terms of what
you're going to be playing and how
you're going to be really in taking the
experience of halo infinite the newer
characters such as weapons such as
the uh the pilot i think they did a
fantastic job explaining to you where
these people came from who they are they
did good character developments between
them and i'm thinking you guys are gonna
like this now let's talk about the
performance
as you guys know i'm playing this on the
xbox series x i'm pretty sure everyone
watching this video knew this i'm pretty
sure it's gonna be the title usually
have it in the title i don't know i made
the title yet but i'm probably gonna
have it in the title
it played really good on the xbox series
x i did have some glitches that happened
like i remember there was one mission i
did where it started me on a map on a
part of the map i couldn't currently get
to where that mission was going down at
so that was a little weird that happened
a couple times but when i reset the game
and went back into it i hit that last
checkpoint and i didn't do it again but
i want to i want you guys to be aware
that that happened i don't know if
that's like a huge thing now keep in
mind i am playing this before the game
came out so these issues are most likely
fixed but i want you to be aware that
there is some issues now it wasn't a
drastic amount of issues for the most
part the game ran fantastic on the xbox
series x but i want you guys to know
that addict had some issues and the game
looks gorgeous i can't say it's like
jaw-dropping i can't say it's a next-gen
experience because the game's not
next-gen only it's clearly on previous
shin game previous gen consoles
but i do think that there is like levels
to this graphics stuff that people love
talking about there's the entry level
this entry you don't want to be
developers don't be here don't be this
guy
then there's the middle area the games
that look really nice but nothing
special it's eye candy but not real good
eye candy then you got the eye candy you
got the games that look amazing and you
know that's pretty much all i have to
say about that i don't think there's
anything wrong with the game looked i
know some of you might be disappointed
how it looks because it doesn't look
like other games but i don't think every
game needs to look identical to another
game i think the art choice and the art
pattern that they went with this was for
a reason because the halo core audience
wanted this style of art design when it
comes to the halo franchise and i think
for the most part everyone's going to be
happy with how this game looks is it
going to satisfy everyone probably not
most of the time you don't satisfy
everyone but i do think it's going to do
enough where people are going to really
enjoy what they see now let's talk about
my all-time favorite you guys know my
favorite thing to talk about on this
channel i love talking about this on
podcasts let's talk about the gameplay
halo infinite gameplay is phenomenal i
loved it i felt like there was so much
freedom when you wanted to play halo
infinite single player and for the most
part the multiplayer is amazing too we
don't got a whole lot of issues in terms
of the multiplayer just some progression
system issue which we'll get to later on
in the video i just personally felt like
halo infinite single player gave me
freedom that i felt like when i play a
game like far cry clearly if you look at
the game and you look at the story
overview that's on youtube you could see
there is some far cry inspirations going
on here now i will be one of those
people with you i'm with everyone that
we're going to talk about whether or not
far cry is a good fit for the halo
franchise and should it have been
implied
i'm here to tell you that i think it
actually did a pretty good job i got it
handed off to 343. i think maybe we're
just getting tired of the far cry
formally and when i say we i mean you
guys because i love far cry i know a lot
of people are getting tired of that type
of formula but i feel like it works well
with halo you know you got your bases
that you take over you got the people
that you want to kill they you know they
got the little targets above their head
and the more of the map you unlock the
more of these people you see and the
more of these bases you unlock the
people you kill the squads that you save
you'll actually put up a currency in the
game it's not really a currency you
don't think you really spend it it's
kind of like a force of how present is
the unsc on this ring and the higher
that is the more that that you get and
the more that you'll walk around you'll
see
marines with snipers marines of rocket
launchers the more stuff that you can
actually have delivered to you such as
hornets such as well you don't think you
can get banshees but you guys get the
point the more of the participation on
the map you do the more stuff you'll
have access to when you want to play the
game
i love this i i really enjoyed this like
i'm not the biggest person on fetch
quest but i was fetching man i was going
out there when you do the the key
targets and you go after these certain
elite people that's in the banished
they'll actually have a a rare weapon
with them and if you defeat them you are
to take that weapon with you back to
your base and you could call it at any
time you want i enjoyed that i enjoyed
the fact that i could go out there and
get squads and get that currency or that
level up as much as i want to and that
where i can call the hornet i want i can
call the warthog that i want i like the
fact that when i got all this stuff
together and i got the warthog out and
they dropped it when i got in there i
had a huge dude i had a marine next to
me with a rocket launcher another marine
on the gatla gun and
together we we we did great things and i
really enjoyed that and i felt like 343
did a good job on the world building on
three on the halo but i do feel like
they could have improved a little bit i
don't know why but i hate when they give
these type of forces that's on a map but
they don't really give an end game why
you need to go out and get that what i
mean by that is look at mass effect 3.
i played that this year i know a lot of
you that watch the podcast you know that
there's a huge thing on what f what
what's mass effect is the best mass
effect and i personally like that you do
stuff in mass effect 3 and it what adds
on to your army you get more people i
could have wanted something like that in
this game maybe you know you have a
final battle in halo infinite and the
more that bar is lifted and the more
it's higher i would like uh you know a
different result that would happen maybe
instead of it being 30 on one with
master chief if you have that
bar up and you take that army that
you've been saving the whole game i
would like to actually see that army
help me at the very last moment now i'm
not going to say that's like a like a
deal break or anything i do feel like
they could have went a little bit more
in detail on the world itself
building up to the final battles in the
final missions in general but i i do
think that you know that's something
that maybe you can look at later 343.
you know it would be cool that all the
stuff that i did throughout the whole
game
mattered at the end it mattered when it
did go into the final mission or you
know have that
that final attack where you're attacking
the banners with everything you have and
that's not i'm not saying that those
type of missions exist in this game i'm
saying that if they would have implied
that kind of system they could have put
those in this game and that's just you
know for future
games 343 but as far as the gameplay i
real i love the grappling hook i love
the shield i mainly just use the graphic
i'm gonna be real with you guys but what
i really enjoyed about this is
the banish of their own people i love
the boss fights man guys the boss fights
there is some serious boss fights in
this game where you'll fight elites that
are going invisible you'll fight stuff
like that and what i really enjoy is the
in-depth that you have fighting these
where you'll be fighting a brute that he
has actual stages on his health you get
his stages down to a certain point and
he changes it up he switches it up he
don't fight you the same way till he
dies i like that they sometimes throw
two of them at you at the same time
i i really enjoy the difficulty that was
in halo
infinite i played it on i started on
uh legendary but i went back down to
heroic about maybe 70 80 through the
game because i wanted to really
experience
a lot of this game and i got to the
point where it wasn't necessarily hard
but i was definitely spending more time
than i would want to i wanted to get a
good amount of time so i could come here
and give you guys my opinion and i
personally felt like if i kept playing
on legendary i was going to pull my hair
out and i'm already got this receding
hairline you guys like i can't pull more
hair i got to keep my hair the way it is
but i feel like you guys are going to
enjoy some of the boss battles the
difficulty in general when it comes to
halo infinite because when you come
across a hunter and halo infinite you
come across a hunter and halo infinite
you feel the threat that this hunter is
supposed to be you feel it now sure
i do think that you should play this in
heroic off the bat because normal is
pretty easy but if you play this in
heroic or higher you're gonna get a
really good decent difficult
out of this game now let's talk about
clearly the elephant in the room the
multiplayer i personally have enjoyed
every bit of the multiplayer i feel like
it is one of the most balanced out
multiplayers that halo's had in a very
very long time is it perfect no i feel
like there's certain guns that need to
be nerfed i don't know what it's called
but the spike gun well once she's a
giant spike
that needs to be nerfed i don't feel
like any gun in halo should kill someone
if it's not a headshot with one shot and
that gun you can shoot them in the elbow
it'll kill them one shot shoot them in
the the leg you'll kill them in one shot
so i feel like that might be nerfed a
little bit i feel like the commando
needs to be buffed a little bit and you
know besides that i actually feel like
the weapon balance of halo infinite is
pretty good now obviously maybe some of
the covenant stuff needs to be buffed a
little bit because i don't really use
that very often so maybe that needs to
be buffed a little bit and i don't
really enjoy
the br starts in ranked i know that's
just my problem and i know that's how
halo is but i've never liked that i've
never liked a game mode that really
demands people use one weapon or one
weapon only i i recommend everyone go to
a ranked match or watch someone play a
ranked match if you don't play ranked
match look at the bottom left like right
here on the on the screen and you're
gonna see br br br br
very
rarely do people use anything else
besides that br in ranked and i get it
that's everyone's favorite go-to weapon
but i love the br but i like a more
diverse halo and unless it's a br or
some kind of power weapon occasionally
you're just gonna see br over and over
again down there and i'm not down for
that now when it talks about the michael
transactions and the progression of the
game and the challenges let's address
the micro transactions first they're
pretty crazy i feel like you know they
need to be tweaked a little bit maybe
stuff shouldn't be so expensive and if
it is expensive make it to where there
is a way to actually unlock the stuff in
game i know that people
probably playing that playing halo
infinite aren't used to the fortnite
formula and what that structure is but
that's pretty much what's going on here
now i feel like
the pricing of the micro transactions
isn't the issue it's more of the
progression and you know let's go over
the progression a little bit
i feel like the progression is
in slight needs of tweaking i feel like
you need to be rewarded for winning
first off uh they did go through they
did an emergency patch where they gave
you 50 xp for what uh for winning games
in general i mean just for playing games
in general so if you think about it like
it's really crazy that 343 didn't think
rewarding players whatsoever for playing
a game was going to be essential and
they had to actually go back and fix
that post launch i think you know they
definitely need to really idolize and
think about what they do here going out
forward now they did have a temporary
patch where you get rewarded for every
game you play throughout the day i think
it's up to eight and then after that
eight you get the standard 50 points
i think that it needs to be expanded a
little bit i think you need to get
rewarded for double kills triple kills
you know anything that you're doing
extra that is making you an essential
teammate if you're playing any form of
objective based games you know take away
a little bit on the double triple kill
still give a little bit of points but
don't give as much as you know maybe
capturing a zone or you know uh
capturing a flag you know you want to
reward the people playing objective
the objective in the actual games you
want to reward them more than people
that just go around killing people and i
think that's the biggest issue that i
see in halo infinite's objective games
is that you're getting a lot of
unbalanced teams because people aren't
playing the objective
now i can't say that's a halo issue by
itself because it's not there's a lot of
issues going on in general when it comes
to first-person shooters or hell even
just multiplayer games in general when
you have an objective match a lot of
people seem to want to kill people
instead of actually playing the
objective but i feel like if you set the
progression system up a little bit to
where you reward people drastically for
playing the objective and reward people
okay with just killing people you're
gonna have a little bit of a balance out
there now let's talk about the
challenges a little bit
there is challenges that you get to
unlock and to get more of the
progression in the battle pass
now how the battle pass is it's ten
dollars you get to
have access to probably 99 to 100 items
of stuff now that won't be an issue but
the issue is originally you were
supposed to do these challenges to level
up now i will say i can see a little bit
where 343 was coming from with this uh
as you can see if you look on there a
lot of them are worth two to three
hundred of peop a pop and there's a lot
of weekly challenges every weekend if
you do all the weekly challenges you get
a special cosmetic item for that week
now i think that's the way that they're
going to be rewarding people here going
forward so you don't have to actually go
out and buy stuff but they need to be
more vocal about stuff like that if
they're going to put some of the stuff
that's in the store now that you could
just go out there and buy just come out
and be vocal that these will be in that
weekly challenge you just got to make
sure you do the all the weeklies for
that challenge now let's talk about the
weekly challenges themselves because
i'm a huge destiny player and i cannot
stand when you demand people to go out
of their comfort zone and play the game
how they would not normally play the
game and i feel like we're getting a lot
of that in halo infinite for instance
you know they want you to play with
certain guns they want you to play
certain matches the problem with that is
you're gonna have people that aren't
really
you know they're not comfortable with
these type of guns and when you make
people play with guns they're not
comfortable with what are you gonna have
unbalanced teams you got people going
for
the challenges over actually playing the
objectives or just going for kill in
general and slayer you're gonna have
people that quit games because they're
not getting the right game mode that
they want now if they want to fix the
game mode thing and keep that in the
rotation for the challenges they're
going to have to imply some type of you
know voting system that was used to be
in the old halos that way you can vote
the map you want and then below that you
can vote what type of game mode you want
so you feel like you're a little bit
more in control of what type of game you
want to play
now i'm not going to say that it's the
end of the world with halo infinite in
the way they did the multiplayer i feel
like the game plays there the solid it's
there the foundation of halo infinite is
definitely there and that's good because
to me the stuff that's wrong with the
game is a couple months of a fix to
tweak stuff around you know maybe their
original vision wasn't something that
you know we were going to as halo fans
and gamers in general except now that
they know that let's see what they do in
the in the cup in the next couple months
to fix that progression system and i'm
willing to to give them the benefit of
the doubt because they gave me such a
solid foundation in terms of gameplay
now overall you guys know how i feel you
guys know addict is this something that
you feel like lived up to the
expectations of halo infinite and i'm
gonna be honest with you guys that did
like sure i had a little bit of
things where i didn't enjoy some of the
stuff that they did in halo infinite's
campaign and it was more towards
narrative focus but it wasn't really the
narrative itself i just felt like there
were certain things that i wanted more
answers from from previous games going
into this being a halo fan that's played
previous halo games but besides that
little nitpick and i do think that is a
nitpick because at the end of the day i
do feel like they told a beginning
middle and end in terms of the let's say
the vanilla of halo infinite and i
that's all i ever really wanted if you
guys remember on iron laura's podcast
every week at 11 a.m during the football
season right now and 1 p.m without the
football season you know that i've been
very very vocal of the only thing i want
is a halo infinite campaign that has a
solid beginning middle and end and i do
feel like halo infinite for the most
part had a great beginning a great
middle and a great end it's just they
needed to put like sprinkles a little
bit more of information throughout the
into to to satisfy my halo lore
nut case because that's what i am at
this point i just i just want more halo
information that's what it really is and
you know hopefully within the next six
months to a year they open up more
information on certain things they
opened up more events more
story-orientated narrative in general
and we'll get a lot more of those
answers that i want because at the end
of the day i think it's not necessarily
that i want that that they're not going
to give me those answers to the stuff
that i want it's just this is a
different form of halo than we've ever
seen this is one of those halos where
you play throughout the next couple
years and it's like i said it's not
necessarily an iron man one two and
three this is more of working our way up
to the avengers to where every six
months to a year they give us that new
content information and they let us play
something else that's going to keep
expanding on the halo infinite universe
until we eventually get to that point at
the very end of halo infinite in their
story maybe five to seven years from now
i know that sounds crazy i don't know if
it's five to seven years i don't even
know if they're going to do stuff six
months to a year i'm throwing out random
numbers but i feel like that's the way
it's going to go and that is when you're
going to feel like you've got all the
information throughout the entire time
you've been playing hail infinite
i think they did a good job guys i think
halo infinite is definitely worth
playing it is an amazing experience that
i really enjoyed from the multiplayer
and how great the the gameplay was and
how great the the actual feel of halo
was and the good middle ground balance
that they were able to achieve by
satisfying people like me over here and
satisfying the casual audience over here
sure sometimes it leans one way to
another but i feel like for the most
part everyone's happy on what the
gameplay of halo's multiplayer is for
sure the progression needs to change
three four three change the progression
you know i do feel like you've done
enough to get yourself a little bit of a
holiday break man go spend time with the
family uh it's not that important we
have a great foundation of gameplay but
three four three when you come back next
year you gotta really hit the ground
floor and get this progression system
fixed maybe even have a limit you know
sure you don't want to give us a bunch
of things because sir let's be real here
some people are going to be killing it
in that multiplayer and you don't want
to give them 6 700 points for getting a
bunch of double kills triple kills give
a limit like 300 you know if you could
do a certain amount of medals at 300
your max you get an extra 300 depending
on your performance and stacked out on
top of everything else but anyway you
guys that's that's the review for halo
infinite i think it's a solid experience
i think it's worth everyone playing and
i think if you're a halo fan you're
going to enjoy this if you're not a halo
fan you're going to enjoy this but like
i said guys
definitely go out there and try it out
it's in game pass i think you know for
game pass you can always dip your toes
in there see if you enjoy it a little
bit and if you really enjoy it and you
really want to support the devs you can
always go out there and buy the actual
campaign or you could just go out there
and buy it it's up to you
i would suggest you know it's definitely
worth the buy but if you want to get
that game pass i don't blame you man i
don't blame you but anyway i appreciate
everyone for coming through man this is
the review on
halo infinite
the single player and multiplayer the
whole package i reviewed it all i do
feel like it's worth your money like i
said definitely put a comment section
below how did you feel about halo
infinite if you're pl if you're watching
this after the game came out and you've
already beat it tell me your guys's
opinion on some of the things that's in
the comment section below now try to
keep it away from spoilers and anyone
watching this if there's any spoilers i
cannot help it so definitely be aware of
the comment section below hit that like
button if you guys enjoyed it and always
catch the iron lures podcast every
sunday at 11 p.m eastern when we're
doing football and i'll and 1pm when
football is no longer in session and
until next time this is lord addict i've
reviewed halo infinite i'm out